good morning John I had pretty much the
worst anxiety dream of all time last
night pretty horrible I don't really
know if I want to share with you but I
guess I'm going to because that's what I
want this video to be about his anxiety
so yeah this is bad prepare yourself I
dreamt that I was a pilot of a
commercial jet and I crashed it me I did
it it was my fault and then I had to go
to all the funerals of the people who
died and talked their families and look
at their coffins give me showing up to
class in my underpants any day I will
take didn't go to class all semester
long and now I have to take the final
sure I actually still have those if
you're in school and you're like I can't
wait to get out of school so I can stop
having these school-based anxiety dream
that never happens you will always dream
that you didn't go to class all semester
long and now you have to go take the
final that will always happen to you
forever until you die our brains are
stupid turns out according to a landmark
study that was completed in 1985 anxiety
is the most common emotion felt injury
which makes me wonder uh whether or not
anxiety is in fact the most common
emotion felt total I feel like right now
anxiety is my most common emotion a lot
going on for me right now I'm about to
finish my album Alan Hardcastle I'm very
excited but also scared I'm going to
working on it for a long time and really
emotionally invested in a lot of my like
time and passion and energy have gone
into it and I know that people aren't
gonna hate it cuz it's good like I know
people are gonna like it but that's what
I know what I feel is that everyone's
gonna hate it and they're all gonna
leave me comments saying why did you
release this piece of crap out into the
world you are such a bad person also I'm
making a video with NASA which is just
like why all the moments of my life
where I'm not thinking oh my god this is
so cool I'm thinking we're god don't
screw up I'm officiating a wedding this
weekend forever couple of my best
friends so yeah my rational side is like
oh my god what an honor you guys really
like me that much but my irrational side
all it heard was hey Hank do you want to
not screw up the most important moment
of our lives and the blender show with
Harry and the Potters tomorrow night
playing shows is always scary more scary
when you're playing it with the coolest
people ever if you live in Missoula you
should come to that there's a link and
then of course you got the most
stressful thing in my life which is
VidCon there's 10,000 thing
and VidCon let's just assume around
10,000 failure rate of 1% super good but
when you got 10,000 things it means that
some things are gonna break and go wrong
and fail when I'm me and I'm looking all
I see is the little fail II things and I
think that that's all that everybody's
gonna see but of course what everybody's
easier than I and 900 things that went
really right and yeah I know most you
were like shut up about VidCon I can't
go it's already sold out but uh next
year 2012 we're gonna have a much bigger
venue so oh this make me realize the
doing stuff is really hard especially
when you're doing it for other people
and you care what they think about you
which is why I think that there are so
many sociopaths and Psychopaths in
positions of power because those people
don't care about other people so when
they do these big important things
they're not freaking stressed out to
sound like rippin their freaking faces
off cuz they're so scared because they
don't care because they're Psychopaths
and then we're shocked when they send
pictures of their penis to random
interns oh we've set the system up for
this it's way too scary to be in a
position of power unless you're a
psychopath
so that worries me like if you want to
do big cool interesting things either
you have to be a psychopath or you have
to be really stressed out and I don't
want to be either of those things but I
also don't want to stop doing cool stuff
so if I'm opening the window of my soul
here but now I'm going to tell you why
it's different for me and how rare this
is that the people I'm doing stuff for
they care about me and their
understanding and wow that's a very
unique and awesome gift and I thank you
all for it and also thank John Ford for
making me stronger without freaking
stressing me out he never does speaking
of which he's not feeling well so
everyone send warm wishes to John is got
some stomach problems which is why he
has not eaten his sandwiches yet so John
feel better and I will see you on
Wednesday